it's finally happening after the success
of deliberation floor we're gonna do
this residency ha ha ha so exciting it
is exciting yeah yeah a little bit about
what we can expect in show what's the
setlist gonna be like greatest hit I
have been listening to found and you
know sir I definitely like to keep that
in mind since you know it was whenever I
did liberation in the fall it had been
you know the last time I had been on
tour was whenever I was pregnant with my
son or back-to-basics so it's been like
a real decade of sorts literally and I
just celebrated his 11th birthday which
was insane so it has to be a family
ascent you know I had to make sure it
was something that I felt really really
good about you know being a mama bear
and so with the success of that and you
know it was just in and now my daughter
who's 4 it was just in her blood to just
you know she was she was actually like
my assistant she'd be like okay mom
let's go next hotel next city like and
they would both get mad at me to be
honest if I didn't include them at some
point if I didn't bring them on stage at
the end so see the key it worked out I
mean yes they'll be they'll be in and
out whenever whenever it's right and I
know school and everything obviously
comes first but I'm such a mama bear and
you know that's always very important
for me that it stays good and grounded
but momma's got to get back to also what
I love to do and as the the stage has
always been my home since I was you know
seven so you know bringing that back and
having you know really just felt right
at home back in the fall you know it
just made sense that now's a perfect
time and having you know gotten back
into you know touring mode and
everything I was able to gather even
more inspiration and see what I want to
do so based off of also you know mama
bear mother mother nature might play
like sort of a you know interesting
inspirational effect and exploring a
little bit of a universal appeal so
there will be a lot of interesting
visuals on this one okay I'm so excited
Jesus at all what the setlist is going
to sound like
the setlist is still coming together so
I definitely don't want to give any of
that away but I'm listening Melissa
my ears are rather open they're open get
on Twitter and tell me what you want to
hear so the show is at Planet Hollywood
which you are in amazing company at that
venom I am they know there's been quite
some some history there and there are
some there is some good company I'm
actually Stefani photos yeah I'm JLo
Britney have you seen any other shows
well I'm actually going to get into the
whole energy and spirit of it I want to
see what the whole thing is about cuz I
really haven't douve into now you hear
things and you see you know from from
afar on and on TV and everything but
like I have yet to go see I'm gonna see
how the audience reacts and their energy
and yeah I want to see you know the
shows and you know all of it it's gonna
be so fun and I'm alive so have you
talked to anyone yet about the
experience have you gotten any advice
from Britney JLo I was thinking of
calling Gwen just to ask pick her brain
and everything and possibly doggoned be
like you doing what's it like I know
she's she's the newest one I think right
now on the Block out so I'm gonna be
like give me the real scoop girl real
story
[Music]
[Applause]
you